A Republican wonders whether colored people,
his word colored people, get coronavirus more
because they don't know or refuse to wash
their hands.
In other words, are dirty immigrants more
likely to get corona virus and they happen
to be the colored ones?
This is the question from a guy who should
never show his face in public again.
His name is Steve Huffman.
He's a Republican state senator in Ohio.
Didn't really have to tell you he was a Republican.
As some of you know, Corona virus is disproportionately
hitting the nonwhite population of the United
States.
There are different reasons why some of our
nonwhite populations in the U.S. have more
underlying health conditions that can be linked
to poverty.
Often, poverty brings with it poor health.
Preexisting conditions appear to predispose
people to more serious cases of coronavirus.
You then also have to account for sometimes
having in access to inferior medical services.
There's a lot of different factors here.
But the point is we know that minorities,
including black Americans, are being disproportionately
hit by corona virus during a hearing about
racism.
Ohio State Senator Steve Huffman asked, Is
it possible that the black and colored population.
Might be getting hit harder by Corona virus
because they don't wash their hands as well
as white people, essentially, so proposing
the idea that these folks are dirtier, they're
not washing their hands as well or as frequently.
Now, get ready for this.
Huffman is a doctor.
He said, quote, My point is, I understand
African-Americans have a higher incidence
of chronic conditions and it makes them more
susceptible to death from Cauvin.
But why?
It doesn't make them more susceptible to just
get kov.
It could it just be that African-Americans
or the colored population do not wash their
hands as well as other groups or wear a mask
or do not socially distance themselves?
That could be the explanation of the higher
incidence.
Now cut.
Ohio Commissioner, on my note at the Ohio
Commission on Minority Health's director Angela
Dawson said what Huffman is asserting is not
the opinion of leading medical experts in
this country.
That probably doesn't come as a surprise to
you.
So either the implication is black people
don't wash their hands correctly because they
don't know how or black people don't wash
their hands correctly because they're dirty
and they don't care to wash their hands.
Pick your explanation as to what Steve Huffman
is saying here.
And then, of course, you know this reference
to the colored population.
Like, what year are we in again?
And for me, this is more proof that we need
more people from younger generations who it
would never even occur to to use this language
in these positions of power.
And it's also a reminder that just because
you're a doctor doesn't mean you're necessarily
smart.
Look at some of the things Ben Carson believes
if you need proof of that.
Now, one last thing.
Let's for a second take seriously the question
of are there handwashing differences among
populations?
Because this has been studied.
We're linking to one such study.
And the conclusions from this study were that
women tend to wash their hands more and better.
In other words, using soap and scrubbing long
enough, women are better hand washers than
men, and nonwhite people are better hand washers
than white people.
When this has been studied disproportionately,
white men are the worst offenders when it
comes to bathroom handwashing.
We're linking to this study in the description
to the YouTube video for this story.
Certainly something to think about.
This guy should never show his face in public
again